honestly feel like um it's because we've
started catering to the people who are
traumatized so like I'm not uh I'm not
saying they shouldn't get help what I'm
saying is that having things like
trigger warnings right there's stuff
like exposure therapy for a reason but
if we start like saying oh yeah this
person can't hear that then it's just
gonna like set them up to be triggered
for it you know what I mean like so if
it becomes normalized and you hear it
day to day then like you're not going to
be triggered and if it still triggers
you that's when you have to go and seek
therapy right to better yourself for me
it's really frustrating to see
mental health and Trauma get users will
most like buzzwords in today's society
because I've seen it in my family I've
seen it firsthand people going through
some real [__] so when people just like
start using that I'm going through a
mental health I'm going through this
like like from an ex-boyfriend it's like
trauma's supposed to be from like war is
that not an X that like cheated on you
exactly when we use them examples people
like
will say I think because every society
every every generation does a new set of
problems right so it's like yes we have
different problems as to problems that
they have 50 years ago but we need to
understand that the world we live in is
much better than it was 100 years ago
like we need to understand that and
embrace it and stop using everything as
like because I think I think the problem
with it is like my brother went through
mental health and I think when I was
watching him go for it it was a 10-year
10-year spent him getting better and
worse and on and off and the best advice
I gave at first I was very sympathetic
and I was like oh don't worry we're here
to help you when he got better
is when I was harsh with him I said look
no one's here to save you know bro you
keep doing this keep doing that that's
you bro that's when he started to
realize when I was more empathetic with
him and sympathetic with him he was
getting worse because he had someone to
kind of lean on and just yeah I think
the same way like the last like breakup
I was in it was kind of like because I
really only talked to my family about
that sort of stuff um for the most part
and my dad was just like shut up
he's like shut up it's over yeah move on
and I was just like damn yeah
I was like you know what he's right he's
right if anything you actually you know
you can move on with your life because
you'll never get it back the time that
we waste yeah that's what that's what my
dad said that's the best thing I think
one of the best things look forward
let's my dad always tells me he's like
look forward you can't you literally
can't change the past and even even my
dad healed like a tough childhood and
growing up people would like there were
comments that he should like go to
therapy about it or whatever and his
mindset was just like why it's over like
what am I what's what's talking about it
gonna do like you want me to talk about
my problems
you know what's interesting that he was
doing something called radical
acceptance and that's something that's
done in therapy so he just did his own
therapy so therapy let's just build
different yeah because look so many
people everybody's different so it's not
like it's therapy just being in a room
and the same results yeah he did his own
therapy and you just have to radically
accept things are the way they are and I
just move on or I accept that okay maybe
I yeah I got blue because I'm ugly yeah
I have to accept that I'm not a 10. move
on it's kind of like a soft topic I
don't know if you know when Morgan
Freeman he done he um I think he got
asked in like a in an interview they're
like oh how do we get over racism and he
said stop talking about it and then I
was at first it's about to when I first
saw that about eight years ago I was
like what the hell is this guy talking
about black man on TV saying stop
talking about race easy enough when I
got old and I realized hold on he's back
on because it's just like we're talking
about what's wrong we're like oh or
mental health like you get over things
by just moving on cracking on moving
forward if we all think about our
darkest and deepest times I think about
them and when I think about them it
makes me feel worse I don't want to talk
about I want to crack and then as soon
as I got that harsh reality bro no one's
here to save you keep moving that's when
I felt better I just feel like life is
so short you're never going to be
younger than you are now you're never
gonna have more energy than you are now
like and that's what I don't know I
always try to get things done like as
quickly as I can because you just never
know how much time you got left and it's
like you're gonna spend the time you
have worried about some [__] that
happened yesterday I can't change it
yeah I think the thing is is that where
all of us here are more on the Practical
side even the girls so yes of course I'm
the same as you uh but I from my
experience as someone as a more of a
clinician I've realized that there are
different there are different
personality their dis personality
disorders there are people who think
very differently from us and the problem
you see them in feminism is that the
problem is that they don't know how to
deal with the trauma so it turns into
hate it turns into feminism it turns
into trying to Exile an entire
gender don't you think that's that's
that's that's the problem because
certain people I get certain people are
great with dealing with trauma they know
how to deal with themselves some people
can't and the problem with them is that
if they can't or choose not to
you don't think because again throughout
all of human history like we had Wars we
had famine we had all of these horrible
horrible things like you don't think on
some level it's a choice
I think the difficulty as well is that
part of it is for example precise orders
um they are actually cultivated from
childhood and they are very problem very
prevalent in broken families people who
have the wrong type of father and mother
figures and it's very sad because what
happens is the child they don't they
learn they don't learn how to
basically be an adult and and deal with
things an adult way so they do very if
you see it basically they're very
childish in the way they do things they
they thought anger Tantrums
because I think this is important yeah
don't we don't whoa I got the answer
really when I ask anyway don't we don't
we think that adding all these different
personality disorders is the problem
I've got because I've seen it as a kid
so I went to a normal school you know
rough kids could whatever was a bit of a
mixture and
an interruptive or dismissive child oh
he's got ADHD this other kid he's got
that he's got that but it's like we it's
like a self-fulfilling prophecy you you
label a 12 year old with ADHD he's gonna
grow he's gonna I've seen kids use as an
excuse I've got ADHD I can't control
myself or I got this because they've
been diagnosed at such a young age with
such issues it's like you just live you
just live on it yeah you can't even with
ADHD you can't do anything about it
otherwise then put yourself on Ritalin
from like being a child which doesn't
seem like because honestly they um like
I'm pretty energetic you know yeah yeah
and I've been like people have diagnosed
me and I would say diagnosed because
it's so easy to get diagnosed I don't
even I don't even count it but it's like
but I was like what am I gonna do I
could take drugs and it's like you don't
sleep on the drugs so I was like I don't
want to do that and my other choice is
to make excuses and say that's
everything and I just just like no I'll
just be normal the other thing is that
there's you might know more about this
about the DSM and the fact that mental
illnesses there's a there's a debate in
what actually is a mental illness like a
an actual one or are you just catering
to the patient if the patient says I'm
feeling this way
uh I don't know there was a I'm not sure
what it means but some sorry I can't
forgot I forgot what the actual term is
but if a woman's been abused from grape
mentioned it first time
um then
there's some sort of uh she's she has a
mental illness that says that she's she
wanted that to happen or something like
really some it just I don't know if
you're familiar what I'm talking about
are you saying that like from what they
learn from their parents or from past
experiences predisposes them again for
it in the future no girl oh
girls are turned on